Today we're going to talk about
sorting, which may not come as
such a big surprise.
We talked about sorting for a
while, but we're going to talk
about it at a somewhat higher
level and question some of the
assumptions that we've been
making so far.
And we're going to ask the
question how fast can we sort?
A pretty natural question.
You may think you know the
answer.
Perhaps you do.
Any suggestions on what the
answer to this question might
be?
There are several possible
answers.
Many of them are partially
correct.
Let's hear any kinds of answers
you'd like and start waking up
this fresh morning.
Sorry?
Theta n log n.
That's a good answer.
That's often correct.
Any other suggestions?
N squared.
That's correct if all you're
allowed to do is swap adjacent
elements.
Good.
That was close.
I will see if I can make every
answer correct.
Usually n squared is not the
right answer,
but in some models it is.
Yeah?
Theta n is also sometimes the
right answer.
The real answer is "it
depends".
That's the point of today's
lecture.
It depends on what we call the
computational model,
what you're allowed to do.
And, in particular here,
with sorting,
what we care about is the order
of the elements,
how are you allowed to
manipulate the elements,
what are you allowed to do with
them and find out their order.
The model is what you can do
with the elements.
Now, we've seen several sorting
algorithms.
Do you want to shout some out?
I think we've seen four,
but maybe you know even more
algorithms.
Quicksort.
Keep going.
Heapsort.
Merge sort.
You can remember all the way
back to Lecture 1.
Any others?
Insertion sort.
All right.
You're on top of it today.
I don't know exactly why,
but these two are single words
and these two are two words.
That's the style.
What is the running time of
quicksort?
This is a bit tricky.
N log n in the average case.
Or, if we randomize quicksort,
randomized quicksort runs in n
log n expected for any input
sequence.
Let's say n lg n randomized.
That's theta.
And the worst-case with plain
old quicksort where you just
pick the first element as the
partition element.
That's n^2.
Heapsort, what's the running
time there?
n lg n always.
Merge sort, I hope you can
remember that as well,
n lg n.
And insertion sort?
n^2.
All of these algorithms run no
faster than n lg n,
so we might ask,
can we do better than n lg n?
And that is a question,
in some sense,
we will answer both yes and no
to today.
But all of these algorithms
have something in common in
terms of the model of what
you're allowed to do with the
elements.
Any guesses on what that model
might be?
Yeah?
You compare pairs of elements,
exactly.
That is indeed the model used
by all four of these algorithms.
And in that model n lg n is the
best you can do.
We have so far just looked at
what are called comparison
sorting algorithms or
"comparison sorts".
And this is a model for the
sorting problem of what you're
allowed to do.
Here all you can do is use
comparisons meaning less than,
greater than,
less than or equal to,
greater than or equal to,
equals to determine the
relative order of elements.
This is a restriction on
algorithms.
It is, in some sense,
stating what kinds of elements
we're dealing with.
They are elements that we can
somehow compare.
They have a total order,
some are less,
some are bigger.
But is also restricts the
algorithm.
You could say,
well, I'm sorting integers,
but still I'm only allowed to
do comparisons with them.
I'm not allowed to multiply the
integers or do other weird
things.
That's the comparison sorting
model.
And this lecture,
in some sense,
follows the standard
mathematical progression where
you have a theorem,
then you have a proof,
then you have a counter
example.
It's always a good way to have
a math lecture.
We're going to prove the
theorem that no comparison
sorting algorithm runs better
than n lg n.
Comparisons.
State the theorem,
prove that, and then we'll give
a counter example in the sense
that if you go outside the
comparison sorting model you can
do better, you can get linear
time in some cases,
better than n lg n.
So, that is what we're doing
today.
But first we're going to stick
to this comparison model and try
to understand why we need n lg n
comparisons if that's all we're
allowed to do.
And for that we're going to
look at something called
decision trees,
which in some sense is another
model of what you're allowed to
do in an algorithm,
but it's more general than the
comparison model.
And let's try and example to
get some intuition.
Suppose we want to sort three
elements.
This is not very challenging,
but we'll get to draw the
decision tree that corresponds
to sorting three elements.
Here is one solution I claim.
This is, in a certain sense,
an algorithm,
but it's drawn as a tree
instead of pseudocode.
What this tree means is that
each node you're making a
comparison.
This says compare a_1 versus
a_2.
If a_1 is smaller than a_2 you
go this way, if it is bigger
than a_2 you go this way,
and then you proceed.
When you get down to a leaf,
this is the answer.
Remember, the sorting problem
is you're trying to find a
permutation of the inputs that
puts it in sorted order.
Let's try it with some sequence
of numbers, say 9,
4 and 6.
We want to sort 9,
4 and 6, so first we compare
the first element with the
second element.
9 is bigger than 4 so we go
down this way.
Then we compare the first
element with the third element,
that's 9 versus 6.
9 is bigger than 6,
so we go this way.
And then we compare the second
element with the third element,
4 is less than 6 and,
so we go this way.
And the claim is that this is
the correct permutation of the
elements.
You take a_2,
which is 4, then you take a_3,
which is 6, and then you take
a_1, which is 9,
so indeed that works out.
And if I wrote this down right,
this is a sorting algorithm in
the decision tree model.
In general, let me just say the
rules of this game.
In general, we have n elements
we want to sort.
And I only drew the n = 3 case
because these trees get very big
very quickly.
Each internal node,
so every non-leaf node,
has a label of the form i :
j where i and j are between 1
and n.
And this means that we compare
a_i with a_j.
And we have two subtrees from
every such node.
We have the left subtree which
tells you what the algorithm
does, what subsequent
comparisons it makes if it comes
out less than.
And we have to be a little bit
careful because it could also
come out equal.
What we will do is the left
subtree corresponds to less than
or equal to and the right
subtree corresponds to strictly
greater than.
That is a little bit more
precise than what we were doing
here.
Here all the elements were
distinct so no problem.
But, in general,
we care about the equality case
too to be general.
So, that was the internal
nodes.
And then each leaf node gives
you a permutation.
So, in order to be the answer
to that sorting problem,
that permutation better have
the property that it orders the
elements.
This is from the first lecture
when we defined the sorting
problem.
Some permutation on n things
such that a_pi(1) is less than
or equal to a_pi(2) and so on.
So, that is the definition of a
decision tree.
Any binary tree with these
kinds of labels satisfies all
these properties.
That is, in some sense,
a sorting algorithm.
It's a sorting algorithm in the
decision tree model.
Now, as you might expect,
this is really not too
different than the comparison
model.
If I give you a comparison
sorting algorithm,
we have these four,
quicksort, heapsort,
merge sort and insertion sort.
All of them can be translated
into the decision tree model.
It's sort of a graphical
representation of what the
algorithm does.
It's not a terribly useful one
for writing down an algorithm.
Any guesses why?
Why do we not draw these
pictures as a definition of
quicksort or a definition of
merge sort?
It depends on the size of the
input, that's a good point.
This tree is specific to the
value of n, so it is,
in some sense,
not as generic.
Now, we could try to write down
a construction for an arbitrary
value of n of one of these
decision trees and that would
give us sort of a real algorithm
that works for any input size.
But even then this is not a
terribly convenient
representation for writing down
an algorithm.
Well, let's write down a
transformation that converts a
comparison sorting algorithm to
a decision tree and then maybe
you will see why.
This is not a useless model,
obviously, I wouldn't be
telling you otherwise.
It will be very powerful for
proving that we cannot do better
than n lg n, but as writing down
an algorithm,
if you were going to implement
something, this tree is not so
useful.
Even if you had a decision tree
computer, whatever that is.
But let's prove this theorem
that decision trees,
in some sense,
model comparison sorting
algorithms, which we call just
comparison sorts.
This is a transformation.
And we're going to build one
tree for each value of n.
The decision trees depend on n.
The algorithm hopefully,
well, it depends on n,
but it works for all values of
n.
And we're just going to think
of the algorithm as splitting
into two forks,
the left subtree and the right
subtree whenever it makes a
comparison.
If we take a comparison sort
like merge sort.
And it does lots of stuff.
It does index arithmetic,
it does recursion,
whatever.
But at some point it makes a
comparison and then we say,
OK, there are two halves of the
algorithm.
There is what the algorithm
would do if the comparison came
out less than or equal to and
what the algorithm would do if
the comparison came out greater
than.
So, you can build a tree in
this way.
In some sense,
what this tree is doing is
listing all possible executions
of this algorithm considering
what would happen for all
possible values of those
comparisons.
We will call these all possible
instruction traces.
If you write down all the
instructions that are executed
by this algorithm,
for all possible input arrays,
a_1 to a_n, see what all the
comparisons, how they could come
and what the algorithm does,
in the end you will get a tree.
Now, how big will that tree be
roughly?
As a function of n. Yeah?
Right.
If it's got to be able to sort
every possible list of length n,
at the leaves I have to have
all the permutations of those
elements.
That is a lot.
There are a lot of permeations
on n elements.
There's n factorial of them.
N factorial is exponential,
it's really big.
So, this tree is huge.
It's going to be exponential on
the input size n.
That is why we don't write
algorithms down normally as a
decision tree,
even though in some cases maybe
we could.
It's not a very compact
representation.
These algorithms,
you write them down in
pseudocode, they have constant
length.
It's a very succinct
representation of this
algorithm.
Here the length depends on n
and it depends exponentially on
n, which is not useful if you
wanted to implement the
algorithm because writing down
the algorithm would take a long
time.
But, nonetheless,
we can use this as a tool to
analyze these comparison sorting
algorithms.
We have all of these.
Any algorithm can be
transformed in this way into a
decision tree.
And now we have this
observation that the number of
leaves in this decision tree has
to be really big.
Let me talk about leaves in a
second.
Before we get to leaves,
let's talk about the depth of
the tree.
This decision tree represents
all possible executions of the
algorithm.
If I look at a particular
execution, which corresponds to
some root to leaf path in the
tree, the running time or the
number of comparisons made by
that execution is just the
length of the path.
And, therefore,
the worst-case running time,
over all possible inputs of
length n, is going to be --
n - 1?
Could be.
Depends on the decision tree.
But, as a function of the
decision tree?
The longest path,
right, which is called the
height of the tree.
So, this is what we want to
measure.
We want to claim that the
height of the tree has to be at
least n lg n with an omega in
front.
That is what we'll prove.
And the only thing we're going
to use is that the number of
leaves in that tree has to be
big, has to be n factorial.
This is a lower bound on
decision tree sorting.
And the lower bound says that
if you have any decision tree
that sorts n elements then its
height has to be at least n lg n
up to constant factors.
So, that is the theorem.
Now we're going to prove the
theorem.
And we're going to use that the
number of leaves in that tree
must be at least n factorial.
Because there are n factorial
permutations of the inputs.
All of them could happen.
And so, for this algorithm to
be correct, it has detect every
one of those permutations in
some way.
Now, it may do it very quickly.
We better only need n lg n
comparisons because we know
that's possible.
The depth of the tree may not
be too big, but it has to have a
huge number of leaves down
there.
It has to branch enough to get
n factorial leaves because it
has to give the right answer in
possible inputs.
This is, in some sense,
counting the number of possible
inputs that we have to
distinguish.
This is the number of leaves.
What we care about is the
height of the tree.
Let's call the height of the
tree h.
Now, if I have a tree of height
h, how many leaves could it
have?
What's the maximum number of
leaves it could have?
2^h, exactly.
Because this is binary tree,
comparison trees always have a
branching factor of 2,
the number of leaves has to be
at most 2^h, if I have a height
h tree.
Now, this gives me a relation.
The number of leaves has to be
greater than or equal to n
factorial and the number of
leaves has to be less than or
equal to 2^h.
Therefore, n factorial is less
than or equal to 2^h,
if I got that right.
Now, again, we care about h in
terms of n factorial,
so we solve this by taking
logs.
And I am also going to flip
sides.
Now h is at least log base 2,
because there is a 2 over here,
of n factorial.
There is a property that I'm
using here in order to derive
this inequality from this
inequality.
This is a technical aside,
but it's important that you
realize there is a technical
issue here.
The general principle I'm
applying is I have some
inequality, I do the same thing
to both sides,
and hopefully that inequality
should still be true.
But, in order for that to be
the case, I need a property
about that operation that I'm
performing.
It has to be a monotonic
transformation.
Here what I'm using is that log
is a monotonically increasing
function.
That is important.
If I multiply both sides by -1,
which is a decreasing function,
the inequality would have to
get flipped.
The fact that the inequality is
not flipping here,
I need to know that log is
monotonically increasing.
If you see log that's true.
We need to be careful here.
Now we need some approximation
of n factorial in order to
figure out what its log is.
Does anyone know a good
approximation for n factorial?
Not necessarily the equation
but the name.
Stirling's formula.
Good.
You all remember Stirling.
And I just need the highest
order term, which I believe is
that.
N factorial is at least
(n/e)^n.
So, that's all we need here.
Now I can use properties of
logs to bring the n outside.
This is n lg (n/e).
And then lg (n/e) I can
simplify.
That is just lg n - lg e.
So, this is n(lg n - lg e).
Lg e is a constant,
so it's really tiny compared to
this lg n which is growing
within.
This is Omega(n lg n).
All we care about is the
leading term.
It is actually Theta(n lg n),
but because we have it greater
than or equal to all we care
about is the omega.
A theta here wouldn't give us
anything stronger.
Of course, not all algorithms
have n lg n running time or make
n lg n comparisons.
Some of them do,
some of them are worse,
but this proves that all of
them require a height of at
least n lg n.
There you see proof,
once you observe the fact about
the number of leaves,
and if you remember Stirling's
formula.
So, you should know this proof.
You can show that all sorts of
problems require n lg n time
with this kind of technique,
provided you're in some kind of
a decision tree model.
That's important.
We really need that our
algorithm can be phrased as a
decision tree.
And, in particular,
we know from this
transformation that all
comparison sorts can be
represented as the decision
tree.
But there are some sorting
algorithms which cannot be
represented as a decision tree.
And we will turn to that
momentarily.
But before we get there I
phrased this theorem as a lower
bound on decision tree sorting.
But, of course,
we also get a lower bound on
comparison sorting.
And, in particular,
it tells us that merge sort and
heapsort are asymptotically
optimal.
Their dependence on n,
in terms of asymptotic
notation, so ignoring constant
factors, these algorithms are
optimal in terms of growth of n,
but this is only in the
comparison model.
So, among comparison sorting
algorithms, which these are,
they are asymptotically
optimal.
They use the minimum number of
comparisons up to constant
factors.
In fact, their whole running
time is dominated by the number
of comparisons.
It's all Theta(n lg n).
So, this is good news.
And I should probably mention a
little bit about what happens
with randomized algorithms.
What I've described here really
only applies,
in some sense,
to deterministic algorithms.
Does anyone see what would
change with randomized
algorithms or where I've assumed
that I've had a deterministic
comparison sort?
This is a bit subtle.
And I only noticed it reading
the notes this morning,
oh, wait.
I will give you a hint.
It's over here,
the right-hand side of the
world.
If I have a deterministic
algorithm, what the algorithm
does is completely determinate
at each step.
As long as I know all the
comparisons that it made up to
some point, it's determinate
what that algorithm will do.
But, if I have a randomized
algorithm, it also depends on
the outcomes of some coin flips.
Any suggestions of what breaks
over here?
There is more than one tree,
exactly.
So, we had this assumption that
we only have one tree for each
n.
In fact, what we get is a
probability distribution over
trees.
For each value of n,
if you take all the possible
executions of that algorithm,
all the instruction traces,
well, now, in addition to
branching on comparisons,
we also branch on whether a
coin flip came out heads or
tails, or however we're
generating random numbers it
came out with some value between
1 and n.
So, we get a probability
distribution over trees.
This lower bound still applies,
though.
Because, no matter what tree we
get, I don't really care.
I get at least one tree for
each n.
And this proof applies to every
tree.
So, no matter what tree you
get, if it is a correct tree it
has to have height Omega(n lg
n).
This lower bound applies even
for randomized algorithms.
You cannot get better than n lg
n, because no matter what tree
it comes up with,
no matter how those coin flips
come out, this argument still
applies.
Every tree that comes out has
to be correct,
so this is really at least one
tree.
And that will now work.
We also get the fact that
randomized quicksort is
asymptotically optimal in
expectation.
But, in order to say that
randomized quicksort is
asymptotically optimal,
we need to know that all
randomized algorithms require
Omega(n lg n) comparisons.
Now we know that so all is
well.
That is the comparison model.
Any questions before we go on?
Good.
The next topic is to burst
outside of the comparison model
and try to sort in linear time.
It is pretty clear that,
as long as you don't have some
kind of a parallel algorithm or
something really fancy,
you cannot sort any better than
linear time because you've at
least got to look at the data.
No matter what you're doing
with the data,
you've got to look at it,
otherwise you're not sorting it
correctly.
So, linear time is the best we
could hope for.
N lg n is pretty close.
How could we sort in linear
time?
Well, we're going to need some
more powerful assumption.
And this is the counter
example.
We're going to have to move
outside the comparison model and
do something else with our
elements.
And what we're going to do is
assume that they're integers in
a particular range,
and we will use that to sort in
linear time.
We're going to see two
algorithms for sorting faster
than n lg n.
The first one is pretty simple,
and we will use it in the
second algorithm.
It's called counting sort.
The input to counting sort is
an array, as usual,
but we're going to assume what
those array elements look like.
Each A[i] is an integer from
the range of 1 to k.
This is a pretty strong
assumption.
And the running time is
actually going to depend on k.
If k is small it is going to be
a good algorithm.
If k is big it's going to be a
really bad algorithm,
worse than n lg n.
Our goal is to output some
sorted version of this array.
Let's call this sorting of A.
It's going to be easier to
write down the output directly
instead of writing down
permutation for this algorithm.
And then we have some auxiliary
storage.
I'm about to write down the
pseudocode, which is why I'm
declaring all my variables here.
And the auxiliary storage will
have length k,
which is the range on my input
values.
Let's see the algorithm.
This is counting sort.
And it takes a little while to
write down but it's pretty
straightforward.
First we do some
initialization.
Then we do some counting.
Then we do some summing.
And then we actually write the
output.
Is that algorithm perfectly
clear to everyone?
No one.
Good.
This should illustrate how
obscure pseudocode can be.
And when you're solving your
problem sets,
you should keep in mind that
it's really hard to understand
an algorithm just given
pseudocode like this.
You need some kind of English
description of what's going on
because, while you could work
through and figure out what this
means, it could take half an
hour to an hour.
And that's not a good way of
expressing yourself.
And so what I will give you now
is the English description,
but we will refer back to this
to understand.
This is sort of our bible of
what the algorithm is supposed
to do.
Let me go over it briefly.
The first step is just some
initialization.
The C[i]'s are going to count
some things, count occurrences
of values.
And so first we set them to
zero.
Then, for every value we see
A[j], we're going to increment
the counter for that value A[j].
Then the C[i]s will give me the
number of elements equal to a
particular value i.
Then I'm going to take prefix
sums, which will make it so that
C[i] gives me the number of
keys, the number of elements
less than or equal to [i]
instead of equals.
And then, finally,
it turns out that's enough to
put all the elements in the
right place.
This I will call distribution.
This is the distribution step.
And it's probably the least
obvious of all the steps.
And let's do an example to make
it more obvious what's going on.
Let's take an array A = [4,
1, 3, 4, 3].
And then I want some array C.
And let me add some indices
here so we can see what the
algorithm is really doing.
Here it turns out that all of
my numbers are in the range 1 to
4, so k = 4.
My array C has four values.
Initially, I set them all to
zero.
That's easy.
And now I want to count through
everything.
And let me not cheat here.
I'm in the second step,
so to speak.
And I look for each element in
order.
I look at the C[i] value.
The first element is 4,
so I look at C4.
That is 0.
I increment it to 1.
Then I look at element 1.
That's 0.
I increment it to 1.
Then I look at 3 and that's
here.
It is also 0.
I increment it to 1.
Not so exciting so far.
Now I see 4,
which I've seen before,
how exciting.
I had value 1 in here,
I increment it to 2.
Then I see value 3,
which also had a value of 1.
I increment that to 2.
The result is [1,
0, 2, 2].
That's what my array C looks
like at this point in the
algorithm.
Now I do a relatively simple
transformation of taking prefix
sums.
I want to know,
instead of these individual
values, the sum of this prefix,
the sum of this prefix,
the sum of this prefix and the
sum of this prefix.
I will call that C prime just
so we don't get too lost in all
these different versions of C.
This is just 1.
And 1 plus 0 is 1.
1 plus 2 is 3.
3 plus 2 is 5.
So, these are sort of the
running totals.
There are five elements total,
there are three elements less
than or equal to 3,
there is one element less than
or equal to 2,
and so on.
Now, the fun part,
the distribution.
And this is where we get our
array B.
B better have the same size,
every element better appear
here somewhere and they should
come out in sorted order.
Let's just run the algorithm.
j is going to start at the end
of the array and work its way
down to 1, the beginning of the
array.
And what we do is we pick up
the last element of A,
A[n].
We look at the counter.
We look at the C vector for
that value.
Here the value is 3,
and this is the third column,
so that has number 3.
And the claim is that's where
it belongs in B.
You take this number 3,
you put it in index 3 of the
array B.
And then you decrement the
counter.
I'm going to replace 3 here
with 2.
And the idea is these numbers
tell you where those values
should go.
Anything of value 1 should go
at position 1.
Anything with value 3 should go
at position 3 or less.
This is going to be the last
place that a 3 should go.
And then anything with value 4
should go at position 5 or less,
definitely should go at the end
of the array because 4 is the
largest value.
And this counter will work out
perfectly because these counts
have left enough space in each
section of the array.
Effectively,
this part is reserved for ones,
there are no twos,
this part is reserved for
threes, and this part is
reserved for fours.
You can check if that's really
what this array means.
Let's finish running the
algorithm.
That was the last element.
I won't cross it off,
but we've sort of done that.
Now I look at the next to last
element.
That's a 4.
Fours go in position 5.
So, I put my 4 here in position
5 and I decrement that counter.
Next I look at another 3.
Threes now go in position 2,
so that goes there.
And then I decrement that
counter.
I won't actually use that
counter anymore,
but let's decrement it because
that's what the algorithm says.
I look at the previous element.
That's a 1.
Ones go in position 1,
so I put it here and decrement
that counter.
And finally I have another 4.
And fours go in position 4 now,
position 4 is here,
and I decrement that counter.
So, that's counting sort.
And you'll notice that all the
elements appear and they appear
in order, so that's the
algorithm.
Now, what's the running time of
counting sort?
kn is an upper bound.
It's a little bit better than
that.
Actually, quite a bit better.
This requires some summing.
Let's go back to the top of the
algorithm.
How much time does this step
take?
k.
How much time does this step
take?
n.
How much time does this step
take?
k.
Each of these operations in the
for loops is taking constant
time, so it is how many
iterations of that for loop are
there?
And, finally,
this step takes n.
So, the total running time of
counting sort is k + n.
And this is a great algorithm
if k is relatively small,
like at most n.
If k is big like n^2 or 2^n or
whatever, this is not such a
good algorithm,
but if k = O(n) this is great.
And we get our linear time
sorting algorithm.
Not only do we need the
assumption that our numbers are
integers, but we need that the
range of the integers is pretty
small for this algorithm to
work.
If all the numbers are between
1 and order n then we get a
linear time algorithm.
But as soon as they're up to n
lg n we're toast.
We're back to n lg n sorting.
It's not so great.
So, you could write a
combination algorithm that says,
well, if k is bigger than n lg
n, then I will just use merge
sort.
And if it's less than n lg n
I'll use counting sort.
And that would work,
but we can do better than that.
How's the time?
It is worth noting that we've
beaten our bound,
but only assuming that we're
outside the comparison model.
We haven't really contradicted
the original theorem,
we're just changing the model.
And it's always good to
question what you're allowed to
do in any problem scenario.
In, say, some practical
scenarios, this would be great
if the numbers you're dealing
with are, say,
a byte long.
Then k is only 2^8,
which is 256.
You need this auxiliary array
of size 256, and this is really
fast.
256 + n, no matter how big n is
it's linear in n.
If you know your numbers are
small, it's great.
But if you're numbers are
bigger, say you still know
they're integers but they fit in
like 32 bit words,
then life is not so easy.
Because k is then 2^32,
which is 4.2 billion or so,
which is pretty big.
And you would need this
auxiliary array of 4.2 billion
words, which is probably like 16
gigabytes.
So, you just need to initialize
that array before you can even
get started.
Unless n is like much,
much more than 4 billion and
you have 16 gigabytes of storage
just to throw away,
which I don't even have any
machines with 16 gigabytes of
RAM, this is not such a great
algorithm.
Just to get a feel,
it's good, the numbers are
really small.
What we're going to do next is
come up with a fancier algorithm
that uses this as a subroutine
on small numbers and combines
this algorithm to handle larger
numbers.
That algorithm is called radix
sort.
But we need one important
property of counting sort before
we can go there.
And that important property is
stability.
A stable sorting algorithm
preserves the order of equal
elements, let's say the relative
order.
This is a bit subtle because
usually we think of elements
just as numbers.
And, yeah, we had a couple
threes and we had a couple
fours.
It turns out,
if you look at the order of
those threes and the order of
those fours, we kept them in
order.
Because we took the last three
and we put it here.
Then we took the next to the
last three and we put it to the
left of that where O is
decrementing our counter and
moving from the end of the array
to the beginning of the array.
No matter how we do that,
the orders of those threes are
preserved, the orders of the
fours are preserved.
This may seem like a relatively
simple thing,
but if you look at the other
four sorting algorithms we've
seen, not all of them are
stable.
So, this is an exercise.
Exercise is figure out which
other sorting algorithms that
we've seen are stable and which
are not.
I encourage you to work that
out because this is the sort of
thing that we ask on quizzes.
But for now all we need is that
counting sort is stable.
And I won't prove this,
but it should be pretty obvious
from the algorithm.
Now we get to talk about radix
sort.
Radix sort is going to work for
a much larger range of numbers
in linear time.
Still it has to have an
assumption about how big those
numbers are, but it will be a
much more lax assumption.
Now, to increase suspense even
further, I am going to tell you
some history about radix sort.
This is one of the oldest
sorting algorithms.
It's probably the oldest
implemented sorting algorithm.
It was implemented around 1890.
This is Herman Hollerith.
Let's say around 1890.
Has anyone heard of Hollerith
before?
A couple people.
Not too many.
He is sort of an important guy.
He was a lecturer at MIT at
some point.
He developed an early version
of punch cards.
Punch card technology.
This is before my time so I
even have to look at my notes to
remember.
Oh, yeah, they're called punch
cards.
You may have seen them.
If not they're in the
PowerPoint lecture notes.
There's this big grid.
These days, if you've used a
modern punch card recently,
they are 80 characters wide
and, I don't know,
I think it's something like 16,
I don't remember exactly.
And then you punch little holes
here.
You have this magic machine.
It's like a typewriter.
You press a letter and that
corresponds to some character.
Maybe it will punch out a hole
here, punch out a hole here.
You can see the website if you
want to know exactly how this
works for historical reasons.
You don't see these too often
anymore, but this is in
particular the reason why most
terminals are 80 characters wide
because that was how things
were.
Hollerith actually didn't
develop these punch cards
exactly, although eventually he
did.
In the beginning,
in 1890, the big deal was the
US Census.
If you watched the news,
I guess like a year or two ago,
the US Census was a big deal
because it's really expensive to
collect all this data from
everyone.
And the Constitution says
you've got to collect data about
everyone every ten years.
And it was getting hard.
In particular,
in 1880, they did the census.
And it took them almost ten
years to complete the census.
The population kept going up,
and ten years to do a ten-year
census, that's going to start
getting expensive when they
overlap with each other.
So, for 1890 they wanted to do
something fancier.
And Hollerith said,
OK, I'm going to build a
machine that you take in the
data.
It was a modified punch card
where you would mark out
particular squares depending on
your status, whether you were
single or married or whatever.
All the things they wanted to
know on the census they would
encode in binary onto this card.
And then he built a machine
that would sort these cards so
you could do counting.
And, in some sense,
these are numbers.
And the numbers aren't too big,
but they're big enough that
counting sort wouldn't work.
I mean if there were a hundred
numbers here,
2^100 is pretty overwhelming,
so we cannot use counting sort.
The first idea was the wrong
idea.
I'm going to think of these as
numbers.
Let's say each of these columns
is one number.
And so there's sort of the most
significant number out here and
there is the least significant
number out here.
The first idea was you sort by
the most significant digit
first.
That's not such a great
algorithm, because if you sort
by the most significant digit
you get a bunch of buckets each
with a pile of cards.
And this was a physical device.
It wasn't exactly an
electronically controlled
computer.
It was a human that would push
down some kind of reader.
It would see which holes in the
first column are punched.
And then it would open a
physical bin in which the person
would sort of swipe it and it
would just fall into the right
bin.
It was a semi-automated.
I mean the computer was the
human plus the machine,
but never mind.
This was the procedure.
You sorted it into bins.
Then you had to go through and
sort each bin by the second
digit.
And pretty soon the number of
bins gets pretty big.
And if you don't have too many
digits this is OK,
but it's not the right thing to
do.
The right idea,
which is what Hollerith came up
with after that,
was to sort by the least
significant digit first.
And you should also do that
using a stable sorting
algorithm.
Now, Hollerith probably didn't
call it a stable sorting
algorithm at the time,
but we will.
And this won Hollerith lots of
money and good things.
He founded this tabulating
machine company in 1911,
and that merged with several
other companies to form
something you may have heard of
called IBM in 1924.
That may be the context in
which you've heard of Hollerith,
or if you've done punch cards
before.
The whole idea is that we're
doing a digit by digit sort.
I should have mentioned that at
the beginning.
And we're going to do it from
least significant to most
significant.
It turns out that works.
And to see that let's do an
example.
I think I'm going to need a
whole two boards ideally.
First we'll see an example.
Then we'll prove the theorem.
The proof is actually pretty
darn easy.
But, nonetheless,
it's rather counterintuitive
this works if you haven't seen
it before.
Certainly, the first time I saw
it, it was quite a surprise.
The nice thing also about this
algorithm is there are no bins.
It's all one big bin at all
times.
Let's take some numbers.
329.
This is a three digit number.
I'm spacing out the digits so
we can see them a little bit
better.
457.
657, 839, 436,
720 and 355.
I'm assuming here we're using
decimal numbers.
Why not?
Hopefully this are not yet
sorted.
We'd like to sort them.
The first thing we do is take
the least significant digit,
sort by the least significant
digit.
And whenever we have equal
elements like these two nines,
we preserve their relative
order.
So, 329 is going to remain
above 839.
It doesn't matter here because
we're doing the first sort,
but in general we're always
using a stable sorting
algorithm.
When we sort by this column,
first we get the zero,
so that's 720,
then we get 5,
355.
Then we get 6,
436.
Stop me if I make a mistake.
Then we get the 7s,
and we preserve the order.
Here it happens to be the right
order, but it may not be at this
point.
We haven't even looked at the
other digits.
Then we get 9s,
there are two 9s,
329 and 839.
All right so far?
Good.
Now we sort by the middle
digit, the next least
significant.
And we start out with what
looks like the 2s.
There is a 2 up here and a 2
down here.
Of course, we write the first 2
first, 720, then 329.
Then we have the 3s,
so we have 436 and 839.
Then we have a bunch of 5s it
looks like.
Have I missed anyone so far?
No.
Good.
We have three 5s,
355, 457 and 657.
I like to check that I haven't
lost any elements.
We have seven here,
seven here and seven elements
here.
Good.
Finally, we sort by the last
digit.
One thing to notice,
by the way, is before we sorted
by the last digit --
Currently these numbers don't
resemble sorted order at all.
But if you look at everything
beyond the digit we haven't yet
sorted, so these two digits,
that's nice and sorted,
20, 29, 36, 39,
55, 57, 57.
Pretty cool.
Let's finish it off.
We stably sort by the first
digit.
And the smallest number we get
is a 3, so we get 329 and then
355.
Then we get some 4s,
436 and 457,
then we get a 6,
657, then a 7,
and then we have an 8.
And check.
I still have seven elements.
Good.
I haven't lost anyone.
And, indeed,
they're now in sorted order.
And you can start to see why
this is working.
When I have equal elements
here, I have already sorted the
suffix.
Let's write down a proof of
that.
What is nice about this
algorithm is we're not
partitioning into bins.
We always keep the huge batch
of elements in one big pile,
but we're just going through it
multiple times.
In general, we sort of need to
go through it multiple times.
Hopefully not too many times.
But let's first argue
correctness.
To analyze the running time is
a little bit tricky here because
it depends how you partition
into digits.
Correctness is easy.
We just induct on the digit
position that we're currently
sorting, so let's call that t.
And we can assume by induction
that it's sorted beyond digit t.
This is our induction
hypothesis.
We assume that we're sorted on
the low-order t - 1 digits.
And then the next thing we do
is sort on the t-th digit.
We just need to check that
things work.
And we restore the induction
hypothesis for t instead of t -
1.
When we sort on the t-th digit
there are two cases.
If we look at any two elements,
we want to know whether they're
put in the right order.
If two elements are the same,
let's say they have the same
t-th digit --
This is the tricky case.
If they have the same t-th
digit then their order should
not be changed.
So, by stability,
we know that they remain in the
same order because stability is
supposed to preserve things that
have the same key that we're
sorting on.
And then, by the induction
hypothesis, we know that that
keeps them in sorted order
because induction hypothesis
says that they used to be
sorted.
Adding on this value in the
front that's the same in both
doesn't change anything so they
remain sorted.
And if they have differing t-th
digits --
-- then this sorting step will
put them in the right order.
Because that's what sorting
does.
This is the most significant
digit, so you've got to order
them by the t-th digit if they
differ.
The rest are irrelevant.
So, proof here of correctness
is very simple once you know the
algorithm.
Any questions before we go on?
Good.
We're going to use counting
sort.
We could use any sorting
algorithm we want for individual
digits, but the only algorithm
that we know that runs in less
than n lg n time is counting
sort.
So, we better use that one to
sort of bootstrap and get an
even faster and more general
algorithm.
I just erased the running time.
Counting sort runs in order k +
n time.
We need to remember that.
And the range of the numbers is
1 to k or 0 to k - 1.
When we sort by a particular
digit, we shouldn't use n lg n
algorithm because then this
thing will take n lg n for one
round and it's going to have
multiple rounds.
That's going to be worse than n
lg n.
We're going to use counting
sort for each round.
We use counting sort for each
digit.
And we know the running time of
counting sort here is order k +
n .
But I don't want to assume that
my integers are split into
digits for me.
That's sort of giving away too
much flexibility.
Because if I have some number
written in whatever form it is,
probably written in binary,
I can cluster together some of
those bits and call that a
digit.
Let's think of our numbers as
binary.
Suppose we have n integers.
And they're in some range.
And we want to know how big a
range they can be.
Let's say, a sort of practical
way of thinking,
you know, we're in a binary
world, each integer is b bits
long.
So, in other words,
the range is from 0 to 2b - 1.
I will assume that my numbers
are non-negative.
It doesn't make much difference
if they're negative,
too.
I want to know how big a b I
can handle, but I don't want to
split into bits as my digits
because then I would have b
digits and I would have to do b
rounds of this algorithm.
The number of rounds of this
algorithm is the number of
digits that I have.
And each one costs me,
let's hope, for linear time.
And, indeed,
if I use a single bit,
k = 2.
And so this is order n.
But then the running time would
be order n per round.
And there are b digits,
if I consider them to be bits,
order n times b time.
And even if b is something
small like log n,
if I have log n bits,
then these are numbers between
0 and n - 1.
I already know how to sort
numbers between 0 and n - 1 in
linear time.
Here I'm spending n lg n time,
so that's no good.
Instead, what we're going to do
is take a bunch of bits and call
that a digit,
the most bits we can handle
with counting sort.
The notation will be I split
each integer into b/r digits.
Each r bits long.
In other words,
I think of my number as being
in base 2^r.
And I happen to be writing it
down in binary,
but I cluster together r bits
and I get a bunch of digits in
base 2^r.
And then there are b/ r digits.
This b/r is the number of
rounds.
And this base --
This is the maximum value I
have in one of these digits.
It's between 0 and 2^r.
This is, in some sense,
k for a run of counting sort.
What is the running time?
Well, I have b/r rounds.
It's b/r times the running time
for a round.
Which I have n numbers and my
value of k is 2^r.
This is the running time of
counting sort,
n + k, this is the number of
rounds, so this is b/r (n+2^r).
And I am free to choose r
however I want.
What I would like to do is
minimize this run time over my
choices of r.
Any suggestions on how I might
find the minimum running time
over all choices of r?
Techniques, not necessarily
solutions.
We're not used to this because
it's asymptomatic,
but forget the big O here.
How do I minimize a function
with respect to one variable?
Take the derivative,
yeah.
I can take the derivative of
this function by r,
differentiate by r,
set the derivative equal to 0,
and that should be a critical
point in this function.
It turns out this function is
unimodal in r and you will find
the minimum.
We could do that.
I'm not going to do it because
it takes a little bit more work.
You should try it at home.
It will give you the exact
minimum, which is good if you
know what this constant is.
Differentiate with respect to r
and set to 0.
I am going to do it a little
bit more intuitively,
in other words less precisely,
but I will still get the right
answer.
And definitely I will get an
upper bound because I can choose
r to be whatever I want.
It turns out this will be the
right answer.
Let's just think about growth
in terms of r.
There are essentially two terms
here.
I have b/r(n) and I have
b/r(2^r).
Now, b/r(n) would like r to be
as big as possible.
The bigger r is the number of
rounds goes down.
This number in front of n,
this coefficient in front of n
goes down, so I would like r to
be big.
So, b/r(n) wants r big.
However, r cannot be too big.
This is saying I want digits
that have a lot of bits in them.
It cannot be too big because
there's 2^r term out here.
If this happens to be bigger
than n then this will dominate
in terms of growth of r.
This is going to be b times 2
to the r over r.
2 the r is much,
much bigger than r,
so it's going to grow much
faster is what I mean.
And so I really don't want r to
be too big for this other term.
So, that is b/4(2^r) wants r
small.
Provided that this term is
bigger or equal to this term
then I can set r pretty big for
that term.
What I want is the n to
dominate the 2^r.
Provided I have that then I can
set r as large as I want.
Let's say I want to choose r to
be maximum subject to this
condition that n is greater than
or equal to 2^r.
This is an upper bound to 2^r,
and upper bound on r.
In other words,
I want r = lg n.
This turns out to be the right
answer up to constant factors.
There we go.
And definitely choosing r to be
lg n will give me an upper bound
on the best running time I could
get because I can choose it to
be whatever I want.
If you differentiate you will
indeed get the same answer.
This was not quite a formal
argument but close,
because the big O is all about
what grows fastest.
If we plug in r = lg n we get
bn/lg n.
The n and the 2^r are equal,
that's a factor of 2,
2 times n, not a big deal.
It comes out into the O.
We have bn/lg n which is r.
We have to think about what
this means and translate it in
terms of range.
b was the number of bits in our
number, which corresponds to the
range of the number.
I've got 20 minutes under so
far in lecture so I can go 20
minutes over,
right?
No, I'm kidding.
Almost done.
Let's say that our numbers,
are integers are in the range,
we have 0 to 2^b,
I'm going to say that it's
range 0 to nd.
This should be a -1 here.
If I have numbers that are
between 0 and n^d - 1 where d is
a constant or d is some
parameter, so this is a
polynomial in n,
then you work out this running
time.
It is order dn.
This is the way to think about
it because now we can compare to
counting sort.
Counting sort could handle 0 up
to some constant times d in
linear time.
Now I can handle 0 up to n to
some constant power in linear
time.
This is if d = order 1 then we
get a linear time sorting
algorithm.
And that is cool as long as d
is at most lg n.
As long as your numbers are at
most n lg n then we have
something that beats our n lg n
sorting algorithms.
And this is pretty nice.
Whenever you know that your
numbers are order log end bits
long we are happy,
and you get some smooth
tradeoff there.
For example,
if we have our 32 bit numbers
and we split into let's say
eight bit chunks then we'll only
have to do four rounds each
linear time and we have just 256
working space.
We were doing four rounds for
32 bit numbers.
If you use n lg n algorithm,
you're going to be doing lg n
rounds through your numbers.
n is like 2000,
and that's at least 11 rounds
for example.
You would think this algorithm
is going to be much faster for
small numbers.
Unfortunately,
counting sort is not very good
on a cache.
In practice,
rating sort is not that fast an
algorithm unless your numbers
are really small.
Something like quicksort can do
better.
It's sort of shame,
but theoretically this is very
beautiful.
And there are contexts where
this is really the right way to
sort things.
I will mention finally that if
you have arbitrary integers that
are one word length long.
Here we're assuming that there
are b bits in a word and we have
some depends indirectly on b
here.
But, in general,
if you have a bunch of integers
and they're one word length
long, and you can manipulate a
word in constant time,
then the best algorithm we know
for sorting runs in n times
square root of lg lg n time
expected.
It is a randomized algorithm.
We're not going to cover that
algorithm in this class.
It's rather complicated.
I didn't even cover it in
Advanced Algorithms when I
taught it.
If you want something easier,
you can get n times square root
of lg lg n time worst-case.
And that paper is almost
readable.
I have taught that in Advanced
Algorithms.
If you're interested in this
kind of stuff,
take Advanced Algorithms next
fall.
It's one of the follow-ons to
this class.
These are much more complicated
algorithms, but it gives you
some sense.
You can even break out of the
dependence on b,
as long as you know that b is
at most a word.
And I will stop there unless
there are any questions.
Then see you Wednesday.